so I'm a big fan of the movie and I feel
like it's coming out at the perfect time
I mean it's the holiday season so it's a
great family movie and it's also uh the
your other movie The Killer had just
come out as well so and the strike has
also just ended so I was curious when
was like the first time you watched this
movie and what was your reaction to it
well uh I I I only watched it once I
screened it and actually don't think I
watched the actual final edit just yet
but um the version I watched I'm fairly
certain is pretty much it um I I loved
it I was laughing basically the entire
time
um and maybe aside from having to
struggle a little bit watching myself in
my own performance I think overall the
film was such a it turned out to be
really great and it such a fun film um a
fun family film and there's a lot lot of
um you know complexities in there that I
think I would assume like everybody
could relate to in some way shape or
form
so it was great for me that's actually
interesting I never thought about that
cuz it's the first time you did a movie
mhm and it's the first time watching
yourself in a movie yeah it's quite
tricky isn't it it is I don't you know
it's kind of like hearing your voice and
your voice message for the first time
you're like oh that's I would say like
cringe was pretty hard yeah that doesn't
change
ever doesn't get better uh I watched it
uh for the first time in Paris um which
sounds very glamorous
actually I was there at the time and I
had like a a little screening it was it
was the finished version it just got
locked I think so really enjoyed it you
know I mean it was such a a fantastic
experience um working on it uh this the
story is such a a heartfelt you know
life
affirming human
story um which I really you know really
affected me when I watched the
documentary and uh and certainly while
we were shooting it just had such a
great
experience working with with everyone on
it um so yeah very hard hard warming to
to to actually watch the finished
product so for you Michael I know you've
done a lot of movies across all genres
but I feel like this is your first true
comedy what was it about this movie that
made you want to take that leap I've
been trying to do comedy for years
nobody would hire me um and ta took a
roll of the dice um I just you know I I
as as a movie fan like I I love watching
comedies you know it's like I think you
can especially you know when it's you
know real human stories you can really
strike home and really hit hit sort of
deep moments very profoundly when it's
within a comedy because when people are
laughing they're more sort of their
they're guard is down and they're more
um available to go on a on a journey I
feel um so you know it was it it was
just perfect opportunity you know ta
is a master in this realm and the
opportunity to work with him was um so
exciting for me and then you know the
material on top of it he was so funny in
the movie hands down thank
you so for you k i everybody who I've
talked to and even H after having seen
the movie myself everybody's raping
about I think your performance the most
and but I was curious how did you since
this is your first movie how did you
come across like the casting for this
did you always want to be a movie star
or oh absolutely not um this was the
cast casting call was just circulating
within like the Polynesian Community
online everyone was super excited about
it and so everyone was sharing it um a
lot of family and friends were shooting
the casting call over to me they like oh
this sounds like you this sounds like
you I was like yeah it does except for
the part that I don't act
so um but yeah so I decided to just go
for it just you know for fun and to get
everyone off my back and I ended up
getting it so yeah here I am awesome
so I know taica does a lot of improv was
there a lot of improvisation on set
100% if not 200% for sure um yeah I
think like the vast majority of the time
we were
improving I don't I don't think there
was ever a scene where we weren't
improving um and you know you you're
you're right to to to sort of you know
state that you know working with K was
was
really um
very impressive you know as a sort of a
firsttimer you know like I've said in
many interviews now it's like there was
just an honesty there and a Simplicity
and that's not easy to do you know going
in improvising we were doing like as you
said it was like you know 90% were just
improvising and to have that sort of
free flow happening and to be relaxed
and present and honest it's you know
just absolute natural it was uh it was
was always quite disarming you know
doing scenes together because it was
just so like truthful it was really
impressive and it's there in the film
you can see it thank you 75 bucks is it
100 so I mean this is a great first
movie it's Tao wititi he's an Academy
Award winner and I know Michael you've
also worked with so many talented
directors and I was curious if there's
any other directors that you have you
know on your bucket list that you would
love to work with next I mean like you
know Coen Brothers big fan scori
Christopher
Nolan uh but I I I mean I feel like I've
been so lucky already you know with the
the directors that I've worked with and
it's all about the directors you know
really um they're the the the the the I
think the real sort of artists it's
their vision and you you know hopefully
find a place to facilitate whatever
they're trying to put on the canvas um
so yeah I just feel super lucky that
I've got to work with the the range of
directors that I have I also I think
this is the year of uh the barheim and I
know Michael you also have the killer
out right now as well and there was all
this debate about oh what movie are you
gonna watch first so I was curious for
somebody who hasn't seen either movie do
you do you have a viewing order for that
oh of which one barbin Heimer or Barbie
and
uper oh oh right um I would do both of
them
together which one should you watch
first I would say if it's what day is it
today Tuesday Tuesday on a Tuesday I
would start with the Killer and uh then
go next go wins on a wedding's day I
would start with next go wins and then
the killer depends on the day depends on
the
day but I still haven't seen Barbie or
Oppenheimer um
because yeah because I was I was in
countries that didn't have um like um
English screenings you know so I was
like ah so I missed it so I I want to
see both of them on the big screen so I
have to do that I only saw barbie so I
can't say I did both okay yeah so my
next question is about I guess going
back to next gool wins with soccer H how
much experience have you had with the
sport did you train before it or um well
I I honestly just as a kid growing up
like during
recess um I'd go and play soccer you
know in the field with the other kids or
after school um that was about the
extent of my soccer experience so right
before filming though we spent a week
training soccer so which didn't help at
all actually it did not help thank
you it did not help at all but yeah it
was a whole week long of from more
morning till Sundown we were out on that
field yeah so well me and three of the
boys and
um I feel like more of them should have
been out there honestly training with us
but I'm terrible at yeah I was like
where's Michael average of best well
thank you so much for talking it's been
lovely talking to both of you and the
movie was fantastic so thank you thanks
so much Nate thank you